in 1950s admiral strauss the chairman of
the Atomic Energy Commission said at the
dawn of the era of nuclear energy that
the living of the atom would make
electricity too cheap to meter and he
was wrong but as a thought experiment
consider if he'd been right consider if
in fact electricity had become too cheap
to meter that something touches every
aspect of the economy became so cheap
that you could waste it just throw it
away
we'd have an electron economy everything
would be driven by electricity our cars
our heat you know we'd be desalinating
water to be irrigating vast swaths of
the country because it would cost us
nothing to do so what's happened now is
that three other technologies that touch
every bit as much of our world as
electricity does are becoming too cheap
to meter bandwidth storage and
processing all the technologies of the
computer revolution are doing exactly
what mmm stamps to us said electricity
would do and what's gonna happen is that
they're gonna transform the world in
every bit as many ways as free
electricity would happen as more and
more businesses become digital
businesses as more and more services
become software as more mobile products
become downloads they all start to move
from their worlds where things are not
too cheap to meter to where they are to
where things get more expensive every
year - any comment where things get
cheaper every year and that means that
the inevitable destination is free the
fact that's the most successful company
in the technology world today Google
Offers everything they do for free is on
the face of it really kind of astounding
they offer services software information
content all of its for free the thing
Yahoo does is for free these are huge
occipital companies that make billions
of dollars and yet they do so their
entire business model is built around
giving things away free to the consumer
all the feedstocks to the digital
economy are are getting cheaper all the
lines are going down now they never
quite hit zero but they get so close to
zero the question is at what point can
you take them from cheap to free now the
difference between one penny and free is
the difference between having to make a
conscious decision to purchase a product
and to just do it
what about the economy that's in
Wikipedia what about the economy that's
in Craigslist what about what about that
stuff for there is no advertising no
money changes hands anywhere in those
economies or all the economies at all
this is what we called it a gift economy
and the gift economy was considered you
know a kind of a fictional a fantasy
thing that only existed in Burning Man
and Berkeley there's no advertising
involved there's no hidden cross-subsidy
there's no hidden transfer of wealth it
is entirely free labor consumed you know
with it with no expectation of payment
or or or monetary exchange so I think
that between open source and the
blogosphere social networking
user-generated content in Wikipedia we
are seeing the creation of a gift
economy which is on massive scale and
really doesn't exist in conventional
economics at all every industry that
becomes digital eventually becomes free
[Music]